après 24 ans d'agriculture chimiques ce
producteur de céréales à sauter le pas
c'est une parcelle de blé qui en 2019
recevait encore de la chimie aujourd'hui
c'est une paire celle qui est enfin de
conversion bio pas d'engrais chimiques
ni de désherbage systématique pour
ludovic réa le déclic intervient en 2016
une année marquée par la sécheresse
monsieur aperçu que même en mettant de
la chimie bah si le temps ne voulait pas
on faisait pas forcément des rendements
en adéquation avec les intrants qu'on
mettait sur les cultures
quand vous avez eu toute votre formation
professionnelle avec de l'agriculture
conventionnelle on recommence tout à
zéro faute ou faut tout réapprendre
donc c'était quelque chose déjà qu'ils
me cheminer dans ma tête depuis un
moment mais c'est vrai que les 2000 2016
a été un élément déclencheur une année
déclencheur dans l'indre les surfaces
exploitées en bio en doublé depuis 2000
15 façon de 10000 à 20000 hectares
aujourd'hui et c'est ici dans la maison
de l'agriculture du département que les
producteurs sont accompagnés dans leur
conversion il va y avoir les premiers
pas à travers les formations donc les
formations qui sont vraiment autour du
cahier des charges de la bio et puis
ensuite les formations techniques
voilà pour améliorer vraiment ses
performances mettre en conformité au
cahier des charges etc et donc à travers
ces formations techniques qui vont
pouvoir acquérir de nouvelles pratiques
robin d'oublier a repris l'exploitation
familiale en 2015 produire 100 % bio une
évidence pour lui
à condition de trouver un équilibre
financier c'est économiquement viable
tanks et les est bio une fois que
j'aurais pu les aider à la conversion
c'est plus compliqué il faut faut que le
système soit bien réfléchi c'est aussi
pour ça que je veux valoriser que je
diversifie me production chaque année
une vingtaine de producteurs berrichon
se lance dans l'agriculture biologique